[موسيقى]
السماء مكونه من نجوم وسدم ومجرات وكواكب
اوضحها النجوم والكواكب وش الفرق بينهن
النجم يخلق الضوء بذاته ولذلك اضاءته
متذبذبه وسهيل كوجنه الحب في اللون وقلب
المحب في الخفقان والكوكب يعكس ضوء الشمس
الساقط على وجهه ولذلك اضاءته ثابته غير
متذبذبه الله نور السماوات والارض مثل
نوره كمشكاتم فيها مصباح المصباح في زجاجه
الزجاجه كانها كوكب دري يوقد من شجره
مباركه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعرب كانوا يسمون الكواكب بالسرايات ليه
لان الكواكب لها حركه تسري بها بين النجوم
واشهر الكواكب بين قوسين السرايات الزهره
المشتري زحل والمريخ وخلال هذه الايام
نبدا نشاهد جرم خافض جدا قريبا من الافق
قبيل شروق الشمس هذا هو كوكب عطارد وايضا
نشاهد كوكب الزهره كجرم لامع بالجهه
الغربيه بعد مغيب الشمس ان يحتقر صغرا
فربما فخما يبدو ضئيل شخصي للنظاري ان
الكواكب في علو محلها لترى صغارا وهي غير
صغاري
[موسيقى]